To sum, the release a few hours ago of
the Google image editing upgrade,
codenamed Nano Banana, will already be
proof we're not in an AI bubble. You can
see the mostly accurate new shadows and
the attention to detail, like the little
metal parts on the bench. In the AI
studio, though, I asked for one flipper
against its head holding an iPhone, and
things weren't quite as good. You could
say it's a true Photoshop replacement if
you don't look too closely. But on the
AI bubble point, for those of a more
factual inclination, there is the rest
of the video because this is about the
coming months and years of our lives.
And the CEO behind CHBT did seem to say
that AI is a bubble. And there was
indeed an MIT study published in the
last few days that claimed that the vast
majority of AI investments were yielding
zero return. Stocks did go down. Context
got lost. But I've read a dozen papers,
studies, and articles released on the
topic of an AI bubble in the last couple
of weeks. So, I've prepared eight points
to consider as we all evaluate whether
AI models have indeed prompted us into a
bubble. And yes, have no fear. Nano
Banana will return. Point number one is
that Samman didn't actually say he
thought AI was a bubble. That was an
editorialized summary by the Verge
journalist of his statement that
investors are quote over excited about
AI. Samman said when bubbles happen,
smart people get over excited about a
kernel of truth on AI. He said, are we
in a phase where investors as a whole
are overexited about AI? My opinion is
yes. Is AI the most important thing to
happen in a very long time? He added, my
opinion is also yes. We'll get to
whether CEOs like Sam Orman actually
understand their tools or can be trusted
in their statements. But let's first
have some context about his observation
of investor over excitement. You've got
to remember that Samman's former chief
scientist at OpenAI fired Sam Orman. His
name is Ilas Suskava. Then left to form
Safe Super Intelligence valued at $32
billion with no product. Maybe that's
why Samman thinks there's investor over
excitement. Then there's Samman's former
CTO, Mera Mirati, who was his brief
replacement as CEO when he got fired,
and who now runs Thinking Machines Lab,
valued at 12 billion, also with no
public product. I wouldn't be surprised
if that's also what he's referring to
when he talks about investor over
excitement. Point two is that the media
can't claim to have foreseen an AI
bubble if they have predicted a bubble
every month for years. Let's take the
Wall Street Journal who a year ago said
that OpenAI's revenue is at least $2
billion. And the company thought it
could double that amount by 2025 this
year. They added that is still a far cry
from the revenue needed to justify
OpenAI's now nearly $90 billion
valuation. Now remember that a
prediction of 2 billion going to 4
billion this year. And here's the
Washington Post earlier poo pooing the
coverage and excitement about OpenAI
hitting 100 million users. The headline
was of an AI hype bubble and they said
that this is just website visits, not
official monthly active users. Okay.
Well, what's the update as of August
2025? OpenAI has hit 700 million weekly
active users. So much for 100 million
being overblown. And it's hit 12 billion
in annualized revenue, so much for 4
billion being overstated. I do
appreciate some of the analogies to the
com bubble, but while pets.com is a dead
link today, I don't think chat.com will
be 20 years from now. Point three, there
have been three recent studies that have
added fuel to the claim that AI is a
bubble. Yes, I've read them all, but for
your own sanity, I'm going to massively
condense the findings into a series of
pathy comments, as is my style. The
first is a McKenzie study cited in the
New York Times that eight in 10
enterprises are not seeing measurable
increased profit as a result of
companywide AI projects. The detailed
there is important companywide AI
projects. First problem, the actual
study cited was done during the
pre-reasoning paradigm of AI in mid
2024. Problem two, the whole McKenzie
study read as more of an advert for the
case studies where AI did have a big
profit boost when coincidentally
enterprises had worked with McKenzie. Of
possible relevance here is the fact that
AI consulting is certainly boosting
McKenzie profits. See this Wall Street
Journal article on that making up 40% of
McKenzie's revenue. The second most
quoted study in the headlines was one
from MIT which was more thorough and
seemingly more recent. They surveyed 153
senior leaders at 52 organizations. Now
it does say in fairness that just 5% of
enterprise projects are getting all of
the value and the vast majority make no
impact positive or negative on the
bottom line. The ones that do well
apparently are those that focus on
business outcomes rather than software
benchmarks. But the far more interesting
part is the more nuanced point that the
study is making which the headlines
miss. I think you guys will quite like
this because the paper says while
official company initiatives that's why
I emphasized earlier companywide
projects official enterprise initiatives
remain stuck on the wrong side of the
Gen AI divide. Employees on the other
hand are already crossing it through
personal AI tools. I think the next
sentence is crucial. This shadow AI
often delivers better return on
investment than formal initiatives.
Translated, when people like you use
your own AI workflows to boost
productivity, you become more reluctant
to use the company AI tools.
Furthermore, this shadow usage creates a
feedback loop. Employees know what good
AI feels like, making them less tolerant
of static enterprise tools. In short,
the benefits you do get from using AI in
your work is often invisible in the
data. bosses might ignore that when it
comes to looking at who to hire and
fire. Or in more formal terms, the Wall
Street Journal puts it like this in an
article titled, "AI's overlooked 97
billion contribution to the economy."
And that, by the way, was 2024, might be
closer to a trillion dollars this year.
What the hell is this invisible surplus?
Well, it's what you would pay to access
AI above and beyond what you actually
pay. Think, in other words, of what you
would pay for your current tools not to
be taken away from you. That might be
slightly more than the $0 or $20 a
month, that's the consumer surplus that
we're talking about. Add that up for an
entire economy and you do get hundred
billion, maybe hundreds of billions of
dollars. Back to the bubble point. That
means if your definition of AI progress
was insane GDP acceleration, as one of
the only remaining OG members of
OpenAI's board predicted would occur,
that's Adam D'Angelo, he expected up to
50% growth per year. Well, if that's
your definition, then that perception is
a bubble that has burst. Before we leave
that MIT study behind though, two last
quick clarifications. I think it's worth
the time given the millions of people
who read the headlines that came of it.
The first is that if you dig into the
appendices, you'll see it was asking
about projects beginning in January
2024. You may remember that it was
September of 2024 that the reasoning
paradigm burst onto the scene with 01
preview from OpenAI. Coding with AI a
year ago was pretty awful, but now it's
a completely different story. Still not
perfect, but way better. And yes, I do
say that in the full knowledge of that
meter report showing that on massive
code bases with early 2025 models, the
impact is pretty mixed for coders. If
you're curious about that, check out my
interview with the lead author of that
study on Patreon. Second quick
clarification, the authors of the MIT
study were encouraging the use of an AI
agent framework, NAND, so had some
reason to suggest businesses were not
yet deriving tremendous value. A bit
like McKenzie, the study did make
brilliant points about the current lack
of memory and adaptability in real time
of models, but offered its framework as
a potential solution to those very
problems. Just something to bear in mind
when you read the headlines. Fourth bit
of context on the AI bubble question,
which is on the nature of incremental
progress. If you look at each week's
progress in AI, it can seem like small
steps forward. Somewhat akin to this new
Helix walking demo from humanoid robot
makers Figure AI. Slow but somewhat
ominously inevitable progress.
Everything seems incremental. But on the
other hand, if you were only shown the
progress in AI at the end of each year,
I think you'd be less inclined to think
of AI as a bubble. And on that year-end
point, I don't just mean on benchmarks
like my own, Symbol Bench, which Elon
Musk seems to have picked up on as a
marker of Gro 4's improvement. You might
not know, but Symbol Bench is basically
a private test of logical reasoning. And
each generation of models does
outperform the last, except for claw 3.7
randomly. But anyway, no, I'm talking
about things like the MMU, testing
models ability to navigate charts,
tables, and technical diagrams at almost
expert level. You could literally just
take a snapshot at the end of each year.
Let me try and do this. So the bloody
American dates, what is that? 23rd of
July. Okay, so we've got what is that?
38%. Then we go forward a year and we're
on 68%. Forward a year and we are on
83%.
I notice on the left it says ensemble of
human experts, medium 82.6, so we're
ahead of that and top human experts
88.6. Trust me, I know some of these
benchmarks are brittle, but if I only
gave you those three data points, you'd
be like, "hm, wow, that's pretty good."
To be honest, I kind of think of
benchmarks as a bit like being photos of
a music concert. They can give you a
snapshot in time of model performance,
not really an immersive experience of
it. What would you have said this time
last year about Genie 3, which enables
you to step into and explore your
favorite paintings? As one commentator
said, "Sometimes I think we're all so
dopamine addicted to the next release
that if two weeks go by without
something major, we're like, man, AI
winter, it's all over." I'm not even
going to get to the near expert level
speech transcription we now have in
2025, V3, lifelike speech generation,
song generation, or even real world
impact. Well, I kind of lied. I am going
to briefly touch on real world impact.
Already systems like Alpha Evolve from
Google have saved Google 0.7% of their
worldwide compute resources. The key was
that the language model could get
feedback. So it kind of knew when it was
hallucinating or when it was on to
something good and it could iterate
rapidly. There was so much real world
impact with its automated solutions that
the bottleneck actually became manual
experimentation. When I look back for
this video, I couldn't believe that that
paper was in May. It felt like years
ago. And stepping back, there's just so
much to take in each week that we even
ignored the official passing of the
touring test in March. Humans literally
could not tell in written conversations
whether they were speaking to another
human or the recently retired GPT 4.5.
Speaking of seeing the human behind the
screen, that reminds me of something.
And I'm going to do something that I
very, very rarely do on the channel,
which is talk about something that isn't
all about AI, just for maybe 30 seconds.
Because the other day I met up with 11
young medical students on electives from
Palestine. They were incredible people
and most of them are using language
models by the way to revise and become
better doctors. They are from the West
Bank so they do currently have access to
basic resources like the internet and
food which is not the case in Gaza. So
massive shout out to the Janine lads who
might be watching and any of you guys
that I might see at the next protest
march in London. Now, 4.5. And if you
thought that so far in this video, every
bit of AI that I've mentioned was just a
flashy demo. Well, then you have to have
an answer for the reasoning
breakthroughs of the last 10 months.
Because in mid 2024, it appeared to be
the academic consensus that models
couldn't reason. What you're seeing is a
classic blocksworld challenge in which
the goal is to get the red block on top
of the blue block. And people said,
well, yes, they could memorize word
sequences to solve such basic Lego-like
scenarios. The data backed that up, and
you can see Gemini 1.5 Pro and GBC40
scoring around half or less on this
challenge. Back then though, if you
switched the words around, so the logic
was the same, but the words didn't
really make sense anymore. Model
performance dropped off a cliff, as you
can see. That's the mystery blocks world
challenge. This was pretty nailed on
proof that language models couldn't
reason and would never be able to
reason. This study was cited by among
others Yan Lun. Here's an example, by
the way, of this more abstract challenge
where you have to understand the
patterns behind the words, not just
memorize the next word. Don't know about
you guys, but I would find this really
quite hard. Then somewhat out of the
blue for the authors, one of whom I
interviewed, along comes 01 preview,
which gets almost 53% on this mystery
blocks world. The authors had to rename
language models to language reasoning
models because they could in fact decode
such jumbled abstractions. Likewise,
this challenge, ARGI1, which I did a
video on back in the autumn, in which
models couldn't predict what would come
next in this sequence. It held out for
almost 6 years and even, by the way,
held out against 01 preview, but fell to
03, the precursor to GBC 5. The author
of that benchmark says it's not just
brute forcing it. These capabilities are
new territory and they demand serious
scientific attention. Francois Chalet,
by the way, now believes that fully
human level AI will arrive by 2030. But
the point is this. We've come a long way
since Chacht in November 2022. And it's
easier to point to flaws in current
models than design a benchmark that will
last even 18 months at the current rate
of AI progress. If you think you found a
slam dunk thing that AI can't do, make a
benchmark of it and see if it lasts 18
months. Because whatever layer of
abstraction you add, LLMs seem able to
climb up to it eventually. Now, it's
true that deriving new physics or
inventing brilliant new literary genres
may require a mountain of such layers,
something that's a real uphill climb to
incentivize in training. as the rich
air, you could call it, of genius level
data gets sparer, I think, the further
up you go. There's another problem,
though. These language models are
pre-inatural pattern finders. But their
intelligence is not perfectly analogous
to human intelligence and is not as
efficiently derived. Thank god a baby
doesn't demand the same kind of energy
or at least wattage as the frontier
models do to train. and prompting models
at inference time demand similar
resources to both training them and
experimenting with new ways to train
them. It all comes from the same
compute. So AI labs have competing
demands on bottleneck resources. Serving
more people sometimes literally comes at
the sacrifice of making a smarter model.
But while we're on Samman, let me turn
to point number six, which is that the
CEOs of these labs have so much to do
these days that I wouldn't be surprised
if they have somewhat lost touch with
the models they're creating. And it's
not just Sam Wolman who oscillates
between saying that AI might generate
OpenAI hundred trillion and that there's
investor over excitement as you saw at
the start between saying that he feels
the AGI with every release and admitting
that the GP5 roll out was a fiasco. You
know what though it's not only him
you've got Sundar Pachai the CEO of
Google who I remember distinctly saying
that progress would be slower in 2025
than it was in 2024. But then Google
Deep Mind went beast mode after that and
started releasing eye-opening models
almost weekly from around I'd say
midJune. He clearly didn't know what was
coming. He would never have said that.
Then there's the CEO of Anthropic, Dario
Ammedday, who said recently, I get
really angry when someone's like, "This
guy's a doomer. He wants to slow things
down." Hm. Why would people say that he
wants to slow things down? Well, let's
look at a transcript of one of his
earliest interviews on the subject in
2023. Sorry for the transcript text, but
Amade repeatedly said that he didn't
want AI acceleration. You may not know
this, but Anthropic had a model clawed
before Chacht and could have released it
first. Just after that decision, he
said, "Yeah, we didn't want a big loud
public release that might accelerate
things so fast that the ecosystem might
not know how to handle it." Later on, he
said, "Given the rate at which the
technology is progressing, there's a
worrying aspect. On balance, I'm glad
that we weren't the ones who fired that
starting gun." I could go on and on
about the changes in sentiment of these
CEOs, but I guess let's just cut to the
point. My only point is I would forgive
a lot of people for thinking that the
CEOs will be the most informed about
these AI models, but they're often not.
Pay more attention to the top
researchers at these companies, not
necessarily the executives of the
companies. Seventh, if you remember, I
started this video by saying that stocks
went down and that's what those articles
were about. Well, that's true, but
they're back up again. Stocks are going
to do what stocks do. Which brings us to
my eighth and final point because even
researchers don't know how many layers
of abstraction an LLM can be made to
think in. And so the leadership of those
companies definitely don't know. And the
media is almost like headless chickens.
The very same outlets that argue that AI
is a bubble report that the job impacts
will soon be grave. Of course, I get
that these news organizations are not
monolithic, but there's somewhat of a
contrast in those two points. But
honestly, even for those of us who pay
attention, for every benchmark that
shows an incredible new ability, like
that of being able to predict the
future, can't cheat on that, increasing
accuracy, see profit arena. Currently,
they have GBC 5 high as being the best
at predictions. There are papers at the
same time, like this one, exposing how
basic visual tricks fool even the best
LM of today. Will the gold medal
accumulating unreleased reasoning model
of OpenAI suffer from the same
hallucinations? Or perhaps the
forthcoming Gemini 3? We shall probably
know by the autumn, which may bring us a
new step change in performance as last
autumn did or may not. I would certainly
be skeptical of anyone who says they are
certain either way. Anyway, that's
enough from me. Thank you so much for
watching. Let me know in the comments if
you think AI is a bubble. I'm off to
play with the image editing tool from
Gemini Nano Banana.